dans la série entretien à philippe
lefait reçoit le chanteur nino ferrer un
retour qu'ils aillent de tendres
souvenirs tête à tête son sud c'est le
quercy son âge ses 60 ans et chaussures
ce sont des santiags et son nom un peu
raccourci c'est nino ferrer hinault
ferrer qui a éprouvé le besoin d'écrire
des textes textes qui sont publiés chez
archambault les belles lettres
et puis dans ses textes qui commence
très tôt il ya premier texte et c'est ma
première question nino ferrer vous avez
écrit en 1937
ceux-ci coin coin coin coin coin coin je
ne te fit rehnab lyon qui faillirent ben
c'est à dire que ma mère a relevé parce
qu'il est évident que je ne vais pas
écrire sagelat quoi mais c'est juste un
gag parce que j'ai du mal à prendre au
sérieux ce qui me concernait le reste
aussi
nous irons dans un monde tellement
ahurissant de d'incohérences qu' on peut
difficilement se prendre au sérieux
pourquoi texte avec un point
d'interrogation pour la même raison
parce que texte sans point
d'interrogation ça a un côté péremptoire
qui ne satisfaisait pas puis par
ailleurs je trouve mes textes tellement
différent de ce qu'on écrit en général
aujourd'hui que je suis quand même à
mener
souvent à douter à me poser la question
est ce que c'est moi qui me trompe ou
est ce que c'est le reste du monde
vous avez toujours douter comme ça non
début non je venais d'un milieu contre
lesquels je n'étais pas en révolte parce
que je viens d'un milieu bourgeois mais
je n'étais pas en révolte contre ma
famille parce que c'était des gens
merveilleux tous noble d'esprit et
généreux cultivé et c est le déclic
finalement ça a été entre 68 disons et
72 par là que ça m'est arrivé j'avais
donc 35 ans ou l'approché des 40 ans et
soixante huit mois j'ai mal réagi au
débat au départ parce que je m'occupais
pas de politique je me souciais pas de
social et de rien épuisement senti quand
même
pardon vous aviez des choses ont quand
même ouais mais ça c'est parce que je
trouvais que les cheveux longs mal et
mieux que les cheveux courts j'ai les
oreilles décollées et le dégrader sam ça
m'allait pas dit tout bas 68 c'est venu
mais me casser la baraque j'étais en
plein en pleine ascension car le succès
planétaire
ça m'a juste cassé la baraque où je
n'étais pas heureux non pas du tout et
après comme je me suis aperçu que
c'était passé des choses importantes et
intéressantes et je disais intentions
sans ticket 72 parce qu'en 72 g
découvrir la différence qu'il ya entre
la musique et la musique c'est à dire la
vraie musique quelle qu'elle soit et
puis celle qu'on entend dans les
ascenseurs et dans les pissotières et ça
a été très important pour moi vous êtes
de plus en plus triste l'âge venant
triste ah non pas triste du tout mais on
doute vous même pas non non non au
contraire mes doutes se sont transformés
en certitudes chemin faisant non pas du
tout je suis assez pessimiste je vois
l'avenir avec beaucoup de crainte pas
par rapport à moi mais par rapport à mes
enfants et aux autres enfants mais je
trouve que la vie est belle choc la vie
est extrêmement gay que voulez vous pour
eux pour vos enfants qu'ils puissent
accomplir leur cycle vital d'une façon
normale choix que c'est ça l'important
est qu'ils puissent pas arrivés par
eux-mêmes à à se fabriquer une vie
depuis dix ans j'ai vécu avec mes yeux
peut-être plus même qu'avec mes oreilles
en fait je ne veux rien dire unis même
dans mes chansons ni dans mes textes je
ne sais pas que je veux exprimer un
message je dis simplement ce que je
ressens et c'est toujours aussi sous une
impulsion sous une réaction va être
exacerbée en général sentimentale que
j'ai créés ou que je peins donc je
compose à 60 ans vous êtes un sage en
l'est forcément plus 60 ans et parce
qu'on a plus d'expérience parce qu'on a
pris quand même à mieux se tenir dans la
vie
parce qu'on a aussi peut-être moins de
désir si on n'a pas ce désir forcené qui
vous arrange les tripes
pourtant à 20 ans c'est pas exactement
pareil mais je trouve que c'est un bel
âge - en fait j'ai remarqué que plus on
avance dans la vie et plus on fait on
est heureux en tout cas ça a été ça a
été mon cas moi je suis amené maintenant
à penser qu'en fait la vieillesse ça
peut être très très beau peut-être même
l'âge d'or de l'homme
la lino ferrer un homme heureux